[Musique]
ces images en ont choqué plus d'un
en plein coeur de l'océan un continent
de plastique mais le pire c'est
peut-être ce qu'on ne voit pas des
particules de plastique de 5 mm et moi
partout partout partout
le problème c'est qu'on est en train de
contaminer l'environnement à une échelle
microscopique
anne-marie hasley et biologiste et
cofondatrice de l'organisation bleus un
organisme pour la conservation de
l'environnement tous les plastiques
jamais conçu existe encore à ce jour
sous forme de plus en plus petit là
parce qu'on parle de micro particules de
poussière il ya une phrase que j'aime
citer souvent qui est assez choc puis
qui marche très bien
le concept il ya plus de micro plastique
dans les océans qui est des toiles dans
la galaxie
à l'heure actuelle et ce plastique vous
en buvez et en manger quotidiennement
bien malgré vous des chercheurs on en
trouvait dans les fruits de mer le sel
le sucre le miel l'alcool l'eau et même
dans le thé et les biberons pour bébés
canada compte bien devenir le premier
pays à interdire en partie un type de
plastique qui dégage du bisphénol a que
plusieurs semaines de provoquer
certaines maladies
kirin cox de l'université de victoria en
colombie-britannique a analysé 26 études
démontrant la présence de plastique dans
notre alimentation
les données compilées réveil qu'on avale
environ 5 g de plastique par semaine
soit entre 39 milles et 5 en 2000
particules de plastique par année c'est
comme si nous ingérions en un an
l'équivalent de 100 fourchette de
plastique et ce ne serait que la pointe
de l'iceberg
nous produisons des matières plastiques
depuis plus de 100 ans pour nos
différents besoins
mais ces polymères se dégradent très
très lentement
les gros objets finesse par
éventuellement devenir la poussière de
plastique cette particule la perversité
de 400 à 1000 ans dépendamment des
polymères dans l'environnement tous les
mollusques les coquillages les palourdes
les huîtres les oursins on en a beaucoup
beaucoup dans
le ces organismes se retrouve à gérer du
micro plastiques dans leur alimentation
les particules de plastique s'invite
aussi dans la chaîne alimentaire
d'organismes marc est encore plus petit
le petit organisme est mangée par un pet
poissons qui mangent et par un moyen
poisson qui finit dans l'assiette du
plus grand prédateur qui est lu ment
probablement que les poissons qu'on va
prendre à l'épicerie ou les moules qu'on
va manger bien il va avoir une certaine
quantité de ces produits-là l'intérieur
donc nous en tant qu'humain ont pu être
exposés à ces particules de cette façon
là isabelle plante est chercheuse en
toxicologie environnementale
qu'est ce qu'on sait en terme de
dangerosité chez l'humain actuellement
de l'ingestion de ces particules chez
l'humain à ma connaissance les à peu
près tout ce qui est connu c'est qu'on
en a découvert dans les selles de
certaines du manque finalement mais à ma
connaissance il n'y a pas grand chose
qui a été faite directement à chez
l'humain on a quelques expériences de
laboratoire ou est-ce qu'on voit des
gens qui ont maintenant exposé des
souris à des nano plastique ou des micro
plastiques ces particules vont surtout
se rendre au niveau du foie en général
on veut c'est qu'ils vont passer la
barrière intestinale cela a été montré
qu'ils vont pouvoir se ramasser dans
l'organisme surtout les nanos plastique
effectivement parce qu'ils sont plus
petits les effets qui ont été reportés
présentement là c'est surtout
l'inflammation au niveau des tissus une
réponse immunitaire look qui a été
reporté tous souhaitent apprendre un
petit peu avec des pincettes parce qu'il
n'y a pas énormément d'études qui ont
été faits ok mais pour concerner
inquiète à ce moment là quand on voit
qu'il ya des effets chez d'autres
espèces fin c'est toujours un peu
inquiétant ce niveau là des études ont
aussi démontré que les métaux lourds
présents dans l'eau peuvent s'accrocher
au micro plastiques augmentant ainsi
leur potentiel de toxicité et pour créer
des objets de plastique ça prend des
agents plastifiants qui eux aussi
migrent dans la nourriture
souvent les agents plastifiants sont
considérés comme des perturbateurs
endocriniens comme les phtalates les bpa
sont des perturbateurs endocriniens
assez connu est ce qu'on voit c'est
souvent des problèmes de reproduction
des problèmes de justement de fertilité
on voit des problèmes immunitaires
maintenant aussi on a établi des risques
avec des problème de métabolisme
d'obésité donc il ya c'est beaucoup plus
large que juste le le système
endocrinien présentement l'étude de 2019
de l'équipe de kirin cox révèle que les
bouteilles d'eau contiennent beaucoup
plus de particules de plastique que
l'eau du robinet
la raison pour laquelle les bouteilles
de plastique en contiennent en moyenne
20 fois plus restent mystérieuses mais
on suspecte que l'entreposage à long
terme ainsi que l'exposition à la
chaleur et au froid entraînerait une
dégradation du matériau ce qui renforce
l'idée de ne pas réutiliser les
contenants de plastique à usage unique
sont utilisés dans les plastiques puis
qu on le chauffe par exemple souvent les
agents plastifiants la bon se libérer
plus rapidement du plastique par exemple
le fameux typique lot de margarine
qu'une fois que les vides on lave les
gens mettent leur sauce à spaghetti le
plogg margarine ont été conçus pour être
à 4 degrés dans votre frigidaire avec de
la margarine
y a pas été conçu pour être congelés
avec la sauce à spaghetti et encore
moins réchauffé au micro
[Musique]
general mills où seul le gouvernement
trudeau est en train de passer une loi
pour bannir le plastique à usage unique
ce qui est vraiment un très gros
débouchés le par rapport à
l'environnement mais aussi pour eux la
santé sociétale
je pense pas qu'ils aient possible
présentement d'avoir aucune exposition
donc l'idée c'est d'essayer de la
réduire le plus possible
plus on a tout parler des micro
plastiques qu'on ingère mais pas celui
auquel on est exposé par voie aérienne
qui touche à un autre un autre sujet
d'anciens dans leur aussi parce qu'il y
en a dans la routine
[Musique]